en el vídeo sobre la inhibición
competitiva vimos que la inhibición
competitiva tiene que ver con un
sustrato o un sustrato potencial y un
inhibidor que compite por la enzima y
quien llega primero consigue la enzima
si el inhibidor llega primero el
sustrato no puede unirse y por supuesto
la reacción no es catalizada si el
sustrato llega primero entonces el
inhibidor no puede unirse y la reacción
si es catalizada el inhibidor y el
sustrato ambos pueden competir por el
sitio activo si estamos hablando de
inhibición competitiva pero también está
la inhibición competitiva a los tehrik a
donde todavía están compitiendo por la
enzima quien llega primero consigue la
enzima pero el inhibidor no
necesariamente se une el sitio activo
más bien se une a un sitio a los teórico
pero es la misma idea si el inhibidor
llega al sitio a los teóricos antes de
que el sustrato según el sitio activo la
conformación de la proteína cambia por
lo que el sitio activo cambia un poco
algo como esto la conformación de la
proteína
cambia un poco y entonces el sustrato
original no le es posible unirse si el
sustrato original se une primero
entonces eso cambia un poco la
conformación del sitio a los teóricos y
entonces el inhibidor no es capaz de
unirse
así que si eso es la inhibición
competitiva donde lo importante es quién
llega primero a la enzima entonces de
qué se trata la inhibición no
competitiva bueno vamos a dibujarlo por
aquí y déjame escribir eso inhibición
inhibición
no competitiva inhibición no competitiva
en general lo que sucede aquí es que
ambos pueden unirse si uno se une a la
enzima no afecta la unión del otro así
que vamos a hablar un poco al respecto
esta es mi enzima
aquí está mi enzima y lo que pasa aquí
es que si el sustrato pueden llegar al
sitio activo entonces por supuesto la
reacción va a poder ser catalizada y
vimos esto aquí arriba el sustrato según
el sitio activo y luego se cataliza la
reacción en este caso el sustrato se
rompió en otras dos moléculas pero en la
inhibición no competitiva lo que ocurre
es que el sustrato puede unirse y el
inhibidor también puede unirse y el
inhibidor se puede unir a un sitio a los
tehrik o aquí tenemos a nuestro
inhibidor y cuando los dos están unidos
observa que no están compitiendo por la
enzima ambos pueden estar unidos a la
enzima esta molécula se puede unir a la
enzima independientemente de si el
sustrato está unido a ella o no
si el inhibidor se une a la enzima el
sustrato todavía puede unirse a la
enzima pero ahora la reacción no va a
proceder así que ahora la reacción se va
a ver así ahora no va a haber una
reacción si esto sucede la única opción
es que ambos se separan de la enzima así
que ahora el sustrato va a dejar el
sitio activo la reacción no fue
catalizada se impidió que cualquier cosa
sucediera y tal vez el inhibidor también
se va y la forma en que mostré esta
inhibición no competitiva lo mostré
sucediendo en un sitio a los teóricos
con el inhibidor uniéndose en un sitio a
los teórico pero en realidad ni siquiera
tiene que ocurrir exactamente así puede
unirse cerca o incluso en el sitio
activo con tal de que no impida que el
sustrato se una al sitio activo incluso
podríamos tener una situación como ésta
este caso es el que normalmente se
enseña para la inhibición no competitiva
donde tienes al inhibidor uniéndose a un
sitio a lo estético pero la idea aquí es
que ambos se pueden unir a la enzima si
el sustrato se une primero entonces el
inhibidor se puede unir todavía y si el
inhibidor se une primero entonces el
sustrato todavía se puede unir pero la
reacción no va a ser catalizada incluso
se puede tener una situación donde el
inhibidor y el sustrato se pueden unir
en el sitio activo o alrededor del sitio
activo así que este es el inhibidor
y este es nuestro sustrato pero una vez
más esta reacción no se va a dar
tenemos la inhibición no competitiva no
están compitiendo por la enzima ambos
pueden unirse a ella su enlace a la
enzima no depende de si el otro está
unido a ella pero si el inhibidor está
unido entonces no va a permitir que la
reacción sea catalizada a diferencia de
la inhibición competitiva en la que el
primero que llegue a la enzima consigue
a la enzima espero que esto te ayude a
aclarar las cosas